did you know the average Billionaire's  wealth disappears within three  generations meaning say there's a  Vanderbilt they made their money how  many Vanderbilts you know today they  have the money why did that happen our  research teams spend time finding out  researching stories after families who  did it right with their generational  wealth lasted for seven generations and  who didn't do it right I'm gonna share  that Insight with you on a webinar uh it  is going to get filled fairly quickly if  you haven't registered yet click on the  link above or below we're going to talk  about generational wealth on this  webinar I'll see you there